Good
afternoon, good evening, good morning
wherever you are. Welcome, welcome,
welcome to Stock. So, we'll wait just a
few moments here as everybody is getting
their their sound and their video and
everything loaded. And if you are on
live with us, um we would love to see
your smiling faces. I would love to see
your smiling faces. It just brightens my
day to see so many people
who are excited and
empowered to find information that can
help them and theirelves,
their families, their communities just
create a healthy and healthier
environment
um with empowering options. So, we do
provide options that you're not going to
hear everywhere. In fact, um very few
places will you hear this. So, we
encourage you to help us share this
information
on Asdoc Live. We have been going for
almost two and a half years. And all of
those programs and replays are available
on askdoccklive.com.
That's askdoclive.com
all one word. You can go there and find
all of our replays. We've got brief
descriptions on the replays. Jonty
Macauier, our web master and our
technical guru, is really good about
getting those replays posted with some
enough information that if you do a
search on the website, it'll come up
with those videos that will include
information about those symptoms. So, we
do try to stay away from medical
terminology, but you know, our body has
symptoms. It's clues that it gives us to
let us know that hey there's something
going on and as Dr. Wall calls them red
warning lights. So with that being said,
welcome to Ask Doc Live. My name is
Rebecca Digs Kak and I will be your host
for the next two hours in providing
empowering information that will benefit
you on your health journey.
Whether you're here just for the
knowledge, whether you're here to find
out what is going to be a best protocol
for you because we will be given some
protocols. We will be taking questions.
So if you have a question for Dr.
Wallik, make sure that you raise your
virtual hand here on the Zoom if you're
on live with us. So go to the Zoom menu,
reactions, click raise hand. Now if you
were invited by somebody specific
and you want to get the protocol or
products that are mentioned within this
program, make sure you get back with the
person that invited you to watch this
show. They took the time and have a
vested interest in making sure that you
also get the information you need
because they want to keep you around.
I there is absolutely no reason we have
to
be average or below average when it
comes to life expectancy and longevity.
And that's information that we're going
to be sharing with you today. So, also
if you're on live with us, make sure
that you have that chat
box open because our incredible co-hosts
will be putting information in that chat
to help you find more information about
what we are talking about today.
So, unfortunately, if you're watching
the replay, that chat's not available.
But every Friday 8:00 a.m. to 10 a.m.
Pacific time, we are here live on
Asklive. And we invite you to get your
personal invitation. Go to
askdoccklive.com
and sign up for our newsletter and that
will get you your invitation each week
with the link to our Asdoc Live program.
You can also reply to that email if you
have questions that you would like to
ask of Dr. Wallik about your personal
condition or that one the condition of
somebody that you um love or care about.
and one of our certified holistic health
coaches will be able to reply to your
email and make sure that you're getting
the information that is going to set
your health journey on a more positive
trajectory. How's that? All right,
everybody. Um I just again want to thank
you all for being here with us and the
content of this information is to
provide educational information only and
it is on the importance of nutrition and
supplementation.
It it was back in the 1930s that it was
determined by the US government that our
food supplies around our country around
our world are empty and void of what the
body needs to survive. Our soil is
depleted of minerals and plants cannot
create minerals without minerals already
being in the ground. Folks, this program
will be sharing those nutritional
options that are available to fill those
gaps through supplementation in a form
that a body can actually readily absorb.
Now, the statements have not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration. The products discussed
are not intended to diagnose, treat,
cure, or prevent any disease. And again,
the information of this Zoom is
forformational purposes. If you are
pregnant, nursing, or taking medication,
please consult your health care
professional before starting on any
supplement program. Now, our good
doctor, Dr. Joel Wallik, has been
instrumental in suing that fine
establishment of the FDA with victories
nine times. Now, these victories have
led to the addition of vital nutrients
added to foods and allowing the
distribution of this information that
has been proven by science to be factual
in the essential need of the
supplementation
against disease.
So, we bring good news. the genetic
theory. If you have been told you have a
genetic condition, well, that genetic
theory has been proven to be incorrect
through the science of epigenetics,
which is the study of how your own
behaviors and environment can cause
changes that affect the way those genes
are expressed. And with epigenetics, you
are an empowered individual and have
more control than you think over how
your body
thrives or survives in this health
journey. So we invite you to feel the
difference with the options that are
provided in this program. And
to guide us,
we are honored to have one of the
founding fathers of epigenetics.
He who is also the recipient of the 2011
Claus Schwarz commemorative medal, the
lifetime achievement on natural medicine
and philanthropy
from the United Nations
which was presented in 2015 here to
guide us with the best options to obtain
or maintain
optimal health. Dr. Joel Wallak. Dr.
Wallik,
welcome to Ask Doc Live. How are you?
>> Thank you so much. Well, thank you so
much for the kind introduction and I'm
very excited today for a variety of
reasons. Number one, of course, we we
have so many of our projects moving
forward and some of them are going to
come to fruit very quickly here. So, I'm
very proud of all the activities that
you and your team have done to bring
that to happen. And uh today is also
veterans day and I want to thank our
veterans um of all you know of our
military disciplines, the army, the
navy, the marines, the air force and so
forth. And um I spent more than 20 years
in the military. I spent seven years um
in the army at Fort Leonardwood uh in
central Missouri with the 105 and 155
howitzers artillery and um that was
quite an experience.
Then let's see here uh I got into the
Air Force and I spent the rest of the 20
years in the Air Force from Elundorf
um in Alaska, Anchorage, Alaska.
[clears throat] Now I didn't spend all
my time in agree last. I was going to
probably about I'd say about 30
different countries um around the world
uh and also so many different I think
all the continents. I went to all the
continents through the air force and um
my my responsibilities were quite wide.
everything from taking care of the guard
dogs because I'm a veterinarian and a
physician, but also uh dealing with the
um uh food supply coming in, made making
sure that was good for our um members of
the military, but also weapons. I was
also involved with receiving weapons and
arming them and making sure they work
properly and didn't blow our own people
up and all that kind of stuff. So, I
covered quite a bit of stuff in the
military. Of course, I'm wearing proudly
my um veterans of the Air Force hat
here. Um
and so I just want to thank all of our
veterans. I want to invite them to join
us. Um they have so much talent and
training and experience in communicating
and observing and um transmitting
information. And if they could apply
that, they could have wonderful
homebased businesses and for their
families and so forth and help put their
kids through college and pay off their
bills and and so forth, especially
there's so many people being laid off
and businesses closing and so forth
because of the pandemic stuff and and so
on. So, I do especially today on
Veterans Day inviting all of our
veterans of every um one of the military
divisions to join us. Okay. And they can
go to Well, what what numbers would you
give out for that, Rebecca?
>> Well, to to start, Dr. Wallik, if they
were invited to this program by somebody
specific, get back with the person
invited them to this program.
>> Absolutely. If you were not invited to
this program by anybody specific, you
can go to askdoccklive.com
and use the contact us and let us know
that you're interested in more
information. But Dr. Wallick, I want to
take a minute to thank you for your
service because not only did you have
service in the Air Force, but you also
had service in the Army. And that's a
lot of time that's been dedicated to
supporting our country and its safety
and vitality. So, thank you so much, Dr.
Wallik, on Veterans Day for your
service.
>> Well, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
It was it was a learning experience over
>> I bet
>> a 20-year period. And so,
I'm very very proud. I think there's a
song. I'm proud to be an American.
>> I'm proud to be an American. Yeah, at
least I know I'm free. There you go.
Yes. I love that song.
>> Yeah. Okay. And so, uh, it's still true
and we have so much good to do for not
only America, but for the world. And so,
let's get it on. And of course, the the
piece you were talking about um where
where the US Senate came in was 1936, US
Senate document 264. They came out and
said, "Our farm soils no longer have
sufficient minerals in them to support
healthy human life, 1936."
And and doctors are still saying, "Oh,
just eat well. You get everything you
need." That's absolutely positively not
true. So I urge you I urge you and of
course I was handing out obituaries of
doctors at meetings. You know, doctors,
they die at 35 while they're running a
marathon or they die at 42 while they're
doing surgery. And um the average
lifespan of emergency room doctors in
America is 58. It doesn't make sense,
right? And so uh I was in a meeting, I
forget where it was. I think it was in
Texas and then a medical doctor, big
guy, comes up to me during the meeting,
right? Just interrupts me speaking and
he comes up to me and he says, "Okay,
well, in front of the whole audience,
they're all cringing out there. They
don't know what's going to happen." And
he says, "Uh, okay, Wall, why are you
giving out all these obituaries of
doctors? What's going on here?" And I
just said out of my mouth and I had
never thought of it before. I just said
only dead doctors don't lie. And so I I
came up with that and um we sold 90
million of those audio cassettes.
90 million. Okay. Before the books were
printed. And so we're getting the word
out there. We need to deal with that.
And so let's go. Now with that said, we
have some very basic things. We have uh
some health stuff that has to do with
nutrition. Okay. We have a book and a CD
and a DVD set, a three-piece set. Book,
CD, and DVD. It's called the the um the
truth about nutrition. And I want
everybody to get this set. Okay? You buy
10 sets, you get a big discount. All
right. Very important.
>> And Dr. Wallik, as a homeschooling mom,
I love this set. to include in our
health education program.
So my son and I have started reading
through this and it's going through the
basics and teaching about the health and
the importance of nutrition.
So if you are a homeschooling family or
grandparents of a homeschooling family,
this would be a fabulous fabulous
Christmas gift because Christmas is
coming fast.
um in helping to provide additional
information that will help your
kids, your grandkids, your great
grandkids have healthier life going
further into life and enjoying life. Dr.
Wallik is I know I used to not look
forward to getting old and now I have no
reservation about getting old. I love
it.
>> Well, you just have to get used to being
old for for 400 years.
>> [laughter]
>> Only if the good Lord wants me to be
here that long, Dr. Wallick. So,
>> okay. And then of course we have
immortality. It's also another book in
the story, but I'm going to get to that
in a minute. But a very important book
in the story uh is Hell's Kitchen. It
goes from a transition from wood and
coal as fuel where we use the ashes
which are 98% minerals and two or 3%
carbon of the wood ashes and coal ashes
for fertilizer and spices put in our
food. We got minerals that way. Well
3:00 in the afternoon Monday September
4th 1882 we went to electricity with
Thomas Edison and suddenly now our
source of our minerals we had for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years went away. And doctors said, "Oh,
just eat well. You get everything you
need." That's absolutely positively not
true. But I urge everybody also to get
the book rare earthman cures. It's a big
one. It's way off on my left hand side.
You got Okay. Rare Earthman cures
chapters 10 and 11. Start at page 272.
It'll tell you how to collect your hair,
how to put it in an envelope or to send
it. Don't forget to put the check in
there because it won't do the test
without the check. And you'll find out
what your status is of your nutritional
minerals. you find out what your status
is of toxic metals like lead and mercury
and and all this um these things uh that
there's probably about 25 different um
toxic metals and so forth and there's s
there's
60 right 60 nutritional minerals
>> 60 essential nutritional minerals yes
>> essential nutritional minerals
>> and trace
>> yeah and so then immortality this is a
five study that we actually spent going
around the world and visiting uh there
you go visiting
um [clears throat]
long live cultures and finding out what
they proactively did proactively avoided
and what they proactively did to what
they did to live to be 120 and 140 and
160 and you know again our emergency
room doctors in America their life
expectancy is 58. Our life expectancy uh
in America um for the average American
is um 75 to 79 depending on whose
numbers you look at. And so we have a
problem here. So what's going on? Well,
it's what we're eating, it's what we're
not eating, it's what nutrients we're
not getting. And so you have to be
responsible for all this. And that's why
we have uh 21 bestselling books and
sets. We have four more coming out. one
of which Rebecca and her team been very
very um prominent in uh the Wallik
Revolution that's coming out here pretty
soon now. I'm very excited about that
because it's the Wallik story from
beginning to now because the end is
about 600 years away I believe. So there
you go. The Wallik revolution [laughter]
and the complete version is at the
printer as we speak. Okay. So thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Becca, and your
team. And um
and I also want to remind everybody that
we have toxic things we have to really
be aware of. And most of them we've been
introduced to by doctors and and people
who are well-meaning. Uh things like
wheat bar oats, they have gluten in
them. They destroy your small intestine,
so you cannot efficiently absorb
nutrients. And then there's buckwheat.
Now buckwheat of course you you find in
pancakes in sort of a cereal kind of
like a um
oatmeal cereal made out of out of
buckwheat and then of course we had also
uh let's see here buckwheat noodles. All
right. And buckwheat um just like wheat
pyan oats have gluten in them, buckwheat
has faggoy in them and the faggoy
inflame your blood vessels and your
organic tissues and glands and
everything and you wind up with a
disease called lupus orthemma. Okay? Get
all these rashes on your face and
everything. you get gut issues. And so
people who eat gluten and buckwheat, oh
my gosh, you are in deep doodoo, deep
trouble. Okay, so lupus, um,
fibromyalgia,
rheumatoid arthritis, irritable valve
syndrome, uh, Crohn's disease, celiac
disease, diverticulitis,
metabolic syndrome, which is obesity,
diabetes, and high blood pressure. And
then uh there's central nervous system
demonization which is um things like
Alzheimer's disease, Parkinson's
disease, MS, multiple scerosis, gamay
syndrome. All of these are are caused by
the white matter of the brain, the
myelin going away makes up 25% of the
brain weight and 25% of your spinal cord
weight. It's cholesterol. Do not take
cholesterol lowering drugs. And eat
three eggs twice a day as an adult. Make
sure your kids are getting eggs. Make
sure if the mother's breastfeeding,
she's eating 83 times a day. Maybe even
three, three times a day. And make sure
that the baby's getting one meal a day
or kids tatty. And make sure the mother
is not eating gluten and not eating
buckwheat because that will interfere
with the nutrition getting into the
breastfed baby. Okay. So, all this stuff
is so important. Um, I just can't uh I
just get breathless when I think about
it. And then for energy rather than soft
drink. Wh
Oh, can't hear you.
>> Okay. I do want to interrupt you since
you were on the buckweek topic. Okay.
>> You have to speak up.
>> Since you're on the buckwheat topic, Dr.
Wallick, I do want to interrupt you for
just a minute because when you are
looking up buckwheat and gluten-free
foods, it is actually something that
comes up as being beneficial. They don't
talk about this chemical that's toxic
within the body that causes severe skin
rashes. And if it's on the outside, it's
on the inside as well. And that is
something that I experienced and didn't
realize it because I thought I was doing
right by using buckwheat as an
alternative. And in many countries, when
I looked up what foods contain
buckwheat, I mean, there's a list of
things that unless you were specifically
looking at the label, you would not know
that there was buckwheat in that food.
So, really, really look at labels. You
don't want wheat, barley, rye, oats, or
buckwheat
on those labels. when as especially not
in the first five ingredients. I mean,
not at all, but still, they're usually
within the first couple ingredients. So,
it doesn't take much to read labels and
find these.
>> Yeah. It's like saying, don't shoot
yourself in the head with a 45. It's
safe to shoot yourself in the head with
a 22. No, you don't want any.
>> Well, I'm gonna I'm gonna say shoot
yourself in the foot. It's still going
to hurt. whether it's a 45 or a 22, it's
still going to hurt really bad and can
cause later issues. So, let's just be
proactive in making sure that we take
those things out of our diets now so
that we're not being affected now or in
the future. So, let's go to energy now.
Dr. Wallick, thanks for letting me
interrupt.
>> Okay. Well, it was good stuff. Good
stuff. And so uh energy of course uh we
want to talk about a rebound um and of
course you take your 90 essential
nutrients and this is what our hair
analysis for. We talked about that with
the book rare earth cures and you need
the nutrients for your body to make
energy repair itself do all that kind of
stuff and then you need the raw
materials and um we have an energy
drink. Okay, it's in a a can, a
canister, and sticks. Um, it has 75
minerals in it. 75 minerals, 25
vitamins, amino acids. There's 30 sticks
in a box. You can take two or three of
these in your pocket during the day. You
know, they only they don't even weigh an
ounce. Okay? And um it's one of those
things where you can either staple them
to or it's kind of dangerous because you
want to be puncturing this with a
staple. So, I like to scotch tape these
to your business cards and hand out your
business card and say, "Hey, we're
looking for people who want to get our
our um energy drink out there." Plus,
our other information, okay, for over um
let's see here, 900 different diseases.
All right, 600 different diseases. Okay,
we need people to get that. And then, of
course, we have the canister, which has
36 servings in there. There's a scoop in
here and you can put one scoop so 36
times into a bottle of water and make
your your rebound that way. Okay. And
then also when I'm at home um we I we
use the cans of rebound. They're 12 oz
cans. There's 12 of them in a case and
they have these little pop tops and um
they have carbonation in them. That
that's kind of a a no no. So what I do
is I pop the tops in two of these cans
before I go to bed at night. put them in
the refrigerator. They off gas the
carbonation during the night time.
They're flat. All the bubbly is gone in
the morning. I drink one with breakfast.
I'll drink the second one with my lunch
or maybe an hour or two after lunch
depending on my schedule when I'm going
to be expending the energy or not. And
so this is where we get the energy. And
every tissue in your body, including
your brain needs energy, right? And
here's where I like um the book and the
CD. It's all in your head. It's all in
your head. There's 12 pairs of cranial
nerves, your spinal cord, all of which
are made in the brain. And when you get
osteoprocess of the skull, what happens
is um
the um the skull squeezes one or more of
these cranial nerves, squeezes the
spinal cord, and there's 37 different
diseases you can get if you have
osteoporosis of the skull. Everything
you know from dental problems, dental
problems to hearing problems, loss of
sense of smell, you can't taste
anything, balance problems, vertigo,
blindness, hearing problems, dizziness,
all this kind of stuff and um uh south
of the skull, sciatica, all this stuff
going on in all your joints and
everything. um hammer toes, um trigger
fingers, all these things are caused by
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing the
spinal cord. And so this is so important
and I I find it kind of interesting. The
doctor's approach say, "Oh, don't do
what Wallik says. Oh, just all those
vitamins and minerals. Let us cut your
leg off and give you an artificial leg.
Oh, let us cut your joints out and let
us give you an artificial hip hip
replace double hip replacement. Let's
give you a double knee replacement. Why
not try my stuff first for 90 days and
see if we can't rebuild your hips? We
can't we'll be we'll rebuild your knees.
We'll rebuild your disc. We'll rebuild
your vertebrae and you won't need that
surgery. See, your doctor pays for his
kids tuition by doing the knee
replacements and the hip replacements
and giving you artificial limbs. That's
how he sends their kids to college.
Okay? Try it for 90 days our way. And
you know, it's one of those things
you're going to spend about, you know,
20 bucks a day or something like that
and rebuild everything. And
it's one of those things where you're
way ahead of the game because there's no
risk of anesthesia problems. And um one
of the ones I really love is the 10th
cranial nerve being squeezed. You get
one of the many things that happens when
you have the 10th cranial nerve being
squeezed is a atrial fibrillation.
Doctors want to anesthetize you, put you
on a surgery table, cut your chest open,
take your heart out, and do what's
called an ablation. They take a hot
branding iron and touch it all over the
heart, looking for the place that's
making your heart go wacko. But that's
not possible because it's not a heart
issue. It's the skull, the 10th cranial
nerve being squeezed, causing the
irregular heartbeat. It's not a heart
problem. It's osteopro to the skull.
When you have AIB, don't let them do
ablation. that has the highest
percentage of deaths and other terrible
things that go wrong with abolition.
It's a very very bad treatment. Don't
volunteer for that one.
Okay. And so with all that said, um I
just get very very excited about our
days here and I'm looking uh at the time
here. Okay. And so I'm gonna um put this
back to you because I can go on and on
and on and on forever here, but if I
don't know how many callers we have, so
I'll throw it to you, Becca, and then
you can choose where we're going.
>> All right, Dr. Wallik, thank you so much
for that information. I think everybody
else can hear me. You've dropped one, so
go ahead and put the other one in your
ear, too, and then you'll be able to
hear me in stereo. Um, but we do we want
to make sure that you can hear because
we do have callers and people with their
hand raised. And we thank you all for
being here with us on Ask Doc Live and
remind you that if you were invited by
somebody specific, make sure that you
get back with them and let them know how
much you appreciate them sharing this
information with you today. Can you hear
me better now, Dr. Wallik?
Yes.
>> Thank you.
>> I love your humor, Dr. Wallik.
>> Thank you. [laughter]
>> Well, Dr. Wallik, let's get to the first
hand that is up. And Susan,
looks like Susan and a friend here are
here with us. Dr. Wallik. Susan, go
ahead. You are Let me make sure you can
unmute. There we go.
>> You're on live with Dr. Wallik. So,
what's going on, Susan?
>> Hi, Dog Wallik. It's a pleasure to meet
you. We're from Meadow Lake,
Saskatchewan.
>> Oh, okay. Canada.
>> That's right. The cold country. Um,
Reynold has recently been diagnosed with
Parkinson's.
>> He's 58, about 200b.
>> Maybe 220.
[laughter]
>> 220. I heard that. Okay.
Kate, does um he have any other issues
such as high blood pressure, diabetes?
>> No.
>> Okay. Do you have any ringing in the
ears? Any tenitis, ringing in the ears?
>> The only symptoms I have are numbness in
my hand, my right hand.
>> Okay.
>> I can't pick up anything really small.
If I try, it's kind of like the nerve is
being stopped.
>> Okay. But you do have tremors that go
along with Parkinson's.
>> No.
Okay.
Um, do you have memory problems?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Uh, do you have vision problems?
>> Okay. Um, what about your sense of
taste? Have you lost your sense of
taste?
>> No, I still have that sense of taste and
sense of humor.
>> Okay, good. What about sense of smell?
>> Not not too strong.
>> Okay.
All right. Yeah, it may. And since you
don't have tremors, which is classic for
Parkinson's, um you may actually have
osteoporosis of skull. Are you slowly
losing vision?
>> Well, my vision is kind of hard to get
glasses because it changes
>> so rapidly.
>> It's gotten poorer since I got my last
pair.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah, it could be the skull
squeezing the optic nerve and optic
nerve atrophy and that's caused by
osteoporosis of the skull. And um do you
have anything going on? Let's see.
Here's one. How many times a night do
you wake up to urinate? Once, three
times, five times?
>> A couple of times.
>> Okay.
>> Depends if I drink water.
>> Okay. Two, three, maybe.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah. You have osteoporosis to the
skull. That's what's causing you to get
up at night to urinate. Um, that's also
what's causing you to slowly be losing
your vision on a rapidly scale because
the skull is squeezing the optic nerve
and cause numbness um in your hand.
um uh by squeezing the spinal cord and
one of the branches of the spinal cord
go to your arm. Okay, and that's good.
And of course getting up at night to
urinate, the skull is squeezing the
spinal cord and the spinal cord is
telling your urinary bladder to urinate.
And so that's why all this is going on.
What about dental problems? Do you have
any dentures or or implants or anything
like that?
>> No, just fillings.
>> Okay. All right.
Let's see here. any bowel problems,
constipation, diarrhea?
>> Um, maybe a little more constipation
since I've been on the vitamins.
>> Okay.
All right. And so, you're already taking
stuff, but I'm just for our viewers and
listeners also. And you're in the
military.
>> Oh, just a carpenter.
>> Okay. You're a carpenter. Okay. Well,
let's see. I think Jesus was a
carpenter.
Yeah, he was maybe maybe I
[laughter]
>> Okay, [clears throat] so um
I want you to get rid of all the bad
foods. And again, this is for all of our
listeners, too. Um everybody's got to
get rid of all the bad foods. No fried
foods, no processed meats of any kind,
no no um um wheat ran oats, uh no
gluten, uh no buckwheat, absolutely no
um processed meats uh of any kind. Um
and then no sugar of course, no carbon
or drinks, they need to go because they
actually neutralize stomach acid so you
can't absorb minerals and digest food
and that kind of thing. And then at 220
pounds, ideally you would take two
healthy brain and heart packs per month.
Two healthy brain and heart packs a
month, full dose, everything twice a
day. Then you need two bottles a month
for MSM. Take three at breakfast, three
at lunch, three, dinner time. and
they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage,
ligaments, tendons, connective tissue,
disc between a vertebrae, bone rates,
bone itself, including the skull. Okay?
Then you need two of our canisters of
collagen peptides. So you can take a
scoop of that with your morning
breakfast and drink and and scoop of
that with your evening drink. Then I
also want you to have the beyond ocux, a
scoop of that with your morning drink,
sc your evening drink. Then vitamin D3,
three of those even in California
because most people, you know, don't get
in their bathing suit and sit out in the
sun for two hours a day like kids do.
And so most adults when they out in the
watching the kids out in the sun,
they're sitting in the shade. And so you
need to take your vitamin D3. Take three
of those twice a day. Be two bottles a
month. And then I also want you to take
because you have stuff going on upstairs
here, I want you to take three eggs
twice a day. Three eggs twice a day with
soft yolks. You need that cholesterol.
Don't forget, don't take any
cholesterol-lowering drugs. You do need
three eggs twice a day today with soft
yolk, soft oil, soft poach. Um, and I
also want you to
let's see here. Uh, what else? Let's
let's go with that. Um,
oh, Synaptive. I do need to take
Synaptive. Take three of those twice a
day. That's two bottles a month. And
that's going to give your brain what it
likes. Also, the brain wants to be happy
and there's three different divisions of
nutrients the brain needs and the
synaptive have um contributions each of
those three groups. Okay, call us every
couple weeks because you're going to
have a great story and um
uh we we deal a lot with Canada. We we
deal a lot with Canada and so they're,
you know, they're our next door neighbor
and um we love Canadians and we um I
used to go up there like almost every
week in Canada, but because of this
COVID thing and all the stuff you had to
go through through the border, it looks
like things are kind of on one hand
getting better and some places getting
worse. So, we'll see. But we do a lot of
Zooms that the Canadians are involved
in, so you might want to check that out.
Okay. So, let's see here. Uh,
I guess
>> all right.
>> Over to you, Becca.
>> Thank you, Susan and Reynold. And I know
that you're in good hands with a coach
that you have. So, um, make sure you get
back with her if you have any questions
and she can get in contact with me if
she has any questions. But she is very
knowledgeable in the products and
protocol that Dr. Wallik has recommended
for you. Now, next, Dr. Wallik, I would
like to go to um a chat question that
was [clears throat] posted by Yavon. And
Yavon has a client. She has is female,
57 years old, 5'5,
140 lb, no medications,
no diagnosises on the brain
or no diagnosis of anything. She's
currently on the brain and heart pack
and has been for about a year. No gluten
in the house. She's compliant on the bad
foods list, no animals, and last year,
um, she had several tiny red blood spots
raise up on her trunk. So, I think
there's a couple different terms for
those. Um,
and she wants to know, and so it's on
the trunk of her body and on her neck.
Um, occasionally.
>> Yeah. Okay. And these these these come
along because of a breakdown
>> of the walls of the little blood vessels
in the skin. The same things are
happening in her lungs in her intestines
because you know at surgery or autopsy
when you open up the intestine you see
these same little red bumps kind of like
half the size of a pee kind of thing.
And um they're bright and red and shiny.
Look like a little berry like a little
cranberry. Okay. Yeah. And these we used
to call them blood blisters when I was a
kid. Okay. Um and they're caused by
deficiency of this the stuff that can
which I say supports
the maintenance of connective tissue
whether it's in the skin or the walls of
the intestine or the lungs or the brain
covering okay the meninges of the brain
uh they can be found anywhere but
there's connective tissue. So, what I
would make sure that she's adding to her
program, uh, she's been using it. She
may have to increase the quantity is I
want her to take the collagen peptides
at her body weight. She can take two
canisters a month. She take a scoop of
that with a breakfast drink, scoop with
her, evening drink. She needs the um,
let's see here. I also want her to have
the MSM uh, take two bottles a month.
should take three at breakfast, three at
lunch, three at dinner time. And that'll
be very very important
to uh deal with the skin, the walls of
arteries and stuff like that and and
veins and capillaries. This is where
this pathology is taking place. And it's
kind of literally a red warning light
because what's going on in the skin is
going on in the brain, going on in the
eyes, going on in the intestine, going
on in the heart valves, and um going on
in the lungs, liver, and glands all over
the place. And so we need to get these
um supporting nutrients in. Also, uh I
like the um let's see here. Let's go
with the Beyond OIO. Why I said that?
Let's go with the
Ultimate Daily Classic. Let's go with
the Ultimate Daily Classic. Uh two
bottles a month per month. Ultimate
Daily Classic. Take three twice a day.
And they're going to support healthy
blood flow, okay? through blocked
capillaries and arteries and veins, but
also um uh support uh the the walls of
the arteries and veins so that they
don't get thickened and and cause
problems and flow problems and so forth.
And sometimes these little red spots
will get better and go away. You know,
you wake up one morning and what's
happened is the connective tissue gets
stronger and that little blister
flattens out and goes back into the skin
and you don't see it anymore. It doesn't
pop and bleed, but it'll just go back
into the skin. Okay? So, that's what
you're looking for. Okay.
>> All right. Thank you so much, Dr.
Wallik. I appreciate that. And
Tony wants to know about cholesterol.
How do I raise my HDL cholesterol?
Because right now Tony's cholesterol is
at 34. And I also heard that olives are
good for that, but not I'm going to just
add in here, not olive oil. Right, Dr.
Wik?
>> Not olive oil. Got to stay away from uh
canned and bottled olives. Okay. Because
who knows how long they've been sitting
on the shelf. Three months, three years,
you don't know.
>> Well, Dr. Wallik, I personally know that
eating an olive tree or eating an olive
right off the tree is not very smart.
>> They have to go through a brine process.
So, what I was thinking of, let's focus
on the other foods that help to raise
good cholesterol.
Eggs.
>> Eggs. What else?
>> Um, red meat.
>> Red meat. And Okay. So, let's talk about
red meat. Dr. Wallak. Do we have to trim
all the fat off of it?
>> No, you want the fat. That's where the
cholesterol is at. Okay. And of course,
red meat, chicken, fish, um, all of
these animal muscle products, okay, have
cholesterol in them. And you want the
fat. You don't want to peel the fat off
a chicken breast and you don't want to
peel the skin and the fat off and throw
it in the garbage or give it to the dog.
The dog will be smiling all the way, you
know, out to see all all the boys and
girls.
>> They'll have a healthier brain than you.
>> That's correct.
>> Let alone the hormones that are being
fed
>> through the good cholesterol.
>> So,
>> all right. So, Tony, I hope that helps
in in some options to help raise the
good cholesterol.
Don't fry anything. Don't fry anything
because if you fry good stuff, it turns
into being bad stuff.
>> That's right. Because it's converting
those molecules. It's making things
crispy. You don't want things crispy. Um
I know in the past somebody has asked
me, "Well, how how can I eat a baked
potato?" Well, you steam it.
You can still get the same goodness on
the inside without making that skin
crispy. You just steam it and then mash
it
>> or but eat it baked
>> and put butter on it
>> and add butter. Yes. And Himalayan salt.
So, um, Dr. Wall, as we're talking about
salt. Yep. We got the seasoned salt. So,
the seasoned salt actually has sea salt
from Australia in it.
>> That's right. Australia, New Zealand.
Right. And uh it has um
top cooked seasoning in there. Okay. And
the piece that a lot of people don't
like from the Himalayan salt we have, we
have pepper in it. Black pepper. And
some people are allergic to black
pepper. They don't like black pepper. Um
but I I like the um I I I like the um
>> So the seasoned salt actually has white
pepper.
>> Yes. And I personally know that there is
a difference in how my body reacts to
white pepper and black pepper because I
cannot have black pepper, but I can do
the seasoned salt with the white pepper.
So
>> there you go.
>> Don't quite understand that, but hey,
that's what works.
>> Yeah. Listen to your body.
>> Well, and let's talk about salt, Dr.
Wallik. So table salt they are stripping
all those minerals out away from the
sodium chloride.
>> That's correct. Now um you have to
appreciate back the first supplements
ever sold was salt. People on the east
coast of all or not the east coast but
the coast of all these continents
surrounded by oceans. Uh they would take
this the sea water and boil it and they
would get this salt and it had all the
trace minerals that were in the oceans
and the Gulf. and so forth. And they
would go inland and sell it for great
amounts of money, okay? Because they
could have people with goiters, you
know, big big thyroids the size of
cantaloupe and they would get on that
sea salt and within weeks that goer
would go away. And so it was like magic.
And so everybody got into having salt.
And then you had clever people saying,
"Well, it's too much work to do this,
that, and the other." So they they would
take all the minerals out and just leave
sodium chloride and they would add back
a few things but um and they weren't
getting all the results that they would
get when they had sea salt with all
those other trace minerals in there from
the ocean. And so that's why we went
with um you have to appreciate when when
they used to say people were the salt of
the earth that's because salt was one of
the greatest things that ever happened
to humanity. It was a proactive
conscious way of getting nutrients into
people, okay, and getting rid of
disease. They could see they could see
that glider going away. They had people
who just couldn't couldn't um get out
and and work. They're just so exhausted.
But then they salt their food, they
they're okay. Um they could digest their
food because you need to make
hydrochloric acid. You have chief cells
in the walls of your stomach to take
salt and turn the salt into hydrochloric
stomach acid. Okay? Anybody who thinks
you don't need salt, oh you should eat
your food, you get plenty. No, don't
don't think that way. Okay. And that's
why we we came up with the Himalayan
salt and the seasoned salt. Right now we
just have on stock seasoned salt and
we're in the process of getting the
Himalayan salt back. But right now we do
have a warehouse full of the season
salt.
But I have, you know, when we when these
things are in, you know, I buy 10
canisters of these things. And so I
still have three or four canisters of
the Himalayan salt left and I use that
at the kitchen table for myself and then
the seasoned salts uh I put out here to
show you know because I know we have
this immediately available.
>> Well let's talk a little bit more about
digestion Dr. Wallik and the importance
of supporting the digestion. Um the salt
mineral full of minerals is important
for that.
>> Um because Angelica has a customer
that's on the 90 essential nutrients.
It's been diagnosed with diabetes, but
she's having vomiting and diarrhea.
The doctor is just recommending amodium
and gravel. I'm not sure what that is.
Um, so that the client has decided to
stay away from food and she's lowering
doses of everything. So we want to make
sure that she is salting her food so
that the food is actually being broken
down in a the right acidic environment
of the digestive system. Right.
>> Correct.
>> But we also have a couple other products
that can help in digestion.
>> Yeah. I I I I like the um let's see
here.
We have all kinds of enzymes. I like our
health. Let's see here. Our digestive
>> Ultimate Enzymes.
>> Ultimate Enzymes. That's a good place to
start. Ultimate Enzymes. Okay. And um
you can take say um two of those, say
five to 10 minutes for each meal with a
couple ounces of water. The ultimate
enzymes.
And [clears throat]
um and then you want to also use if you
have it the Himalayan salt. If you
don't, you want to use a seasoned salt
because it has the the minerals from the
oceans around Australia, around New
Zealand, around the United States,
around Hawaii. Okay. And so we have all
this stuff and
it's the cheapest doctor you can get is
salt.
>> It Yeah, it does. It does do a lot when
it comes to digestion and food. And if
our food's not being broken down, we're
not getting the nutrients even out of
the food, even if there's limited
nutrients there. But one thing that I
like, Dr. Wall, like in between foods,
especially if I've had like a really big
meal and I'm just feeling,
you know, not so great. Digest FX
is amazing
at being able to help relieve that
bloatedness
and and just that ick feel. And then I
also like the root beer belly. And
sometimes that's just dessert. It tastes
okay. Forget about dessert. You just
take some root beer belly. Helps to
break down the food that you've already
eaten. It gives some pre and probiotics
in there also um to help create a great
gut.
>> And the root beer belly was designed for
kids to get it into kids. Okay.
>> And it does taste like root beer.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, and Heather, one of our co-hosts,
she loves root beer belly after having
[laughter] after having a gastro surgery
that went bad. Root Beer Belly is one of
her best friends.
>> Yeah. So,
>> and so you know if you have any burping,
belching, bloating, gas coming out the
other end, that kind of stuff, give it a
shot. You can't go wrong. Give, you
know, do the root beer belly. That's in
addition to all the other stuff. You
can't stop the other stuff just to do
your belly.
>> It's an add-on.
>> No. So, most definitely. But it all
starts with the foundation, Dr. Wallik.
And that is the 90 essential nutrients,
uh minerals, that's essential and trace
minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 amino acids,
three essential fatty acids, and if you
add it all up, it's actually 91, but
let's just say 90 essential nutrients.
And that's a foundation. A foundation
that you can take each and every day and
not have to worry about what you're
getting in your food. I mean, yes, we
want to eat healthy. You cannot outs
supplement a bad, lousy diet. I have
many people that have thought that and
it just doesn't work as well for them.
So, I highly encourage you to adopt the
good foods bad foods list. If you do not
have a copy of the good foods, bad foods
list and you're on with us in Zoom,
check the chat. Our co-hosts have been
putting the link to that good foods, bad
foods list in the chat. It is also found
on our website at askdoccklive.com.
You can do a search there for the good
foods bad foods list and that goes
through
all of the things that you want to stay
away from. But most importantly, the
things that you want to add to your
diet. I don't know that. Okay, you're
gonna correct me on that one. I know you
are.
>> The most important thing is to stay away
from the bad foods.
>> But for me,
>> both. You have to do both.
>> When you tell me I can't have something,
I need
>> oxygen. What What's more important,
oxygen or water? You need them both.
>> You need them both. That's right. That's
right. So [snorts] I love the fact that
there are alternatives that are offered
there with the good food. So you don't
have to feel like you are being deprived
of anything because I mean there's a lot
of good stuff that we can eat. Um but
as in that document stated in n was it
1936 Dr. Wallik
>> 1936.
>> Our food does not have the nutrition
that it used to. And think about 1936.
That was almost 90 years ago.
Was it n Yeah, almost 90 years ago. And
we've been continually farming the land,
depleting it even further.
And primarily what farmers put in large
um fields is NPK, nitrogen phosphorus,
potassium, because that'll give him
maximum growth in terms of tons and
bushels per acre is where he makes his
money. And then when he makes some feed
for his pigs and his horses and his cows
and sheep out of that, he'll add
vitamins and minerals to it for them.
But you're getting the corn and and and
uh the wheat and all buckwheat and all
the bad stuff with just three nutrients
in them uh and all the bad stuff that
goes along with it. And and so that it's
a very bad situation.
>> So bas basically we're getting the
filler
and a little bit of nutrition unless
we're intentionally giving our body that
nutrition, right?
>> Yep. And the previous person we were
talking about had the diabetes. Don't
forget the sweeties.
>> And the sweeties. Absolutely. Because
that gives the nutrients that important
to help to con
>> They're not important. They're
essential.
>> Essential. Essential.
>> They're essential because type two
diabetes makes up 98% of the diabetic
population. And it's 100% a nutritional
deficiency. It is not genetic. It's not
autoimmune. It's not anything else. It's
just a nutritional deficiency of two
elements. Which one is it? Which one is
it? Well, you get the program, you'll
see. You get the book, you'll see. And
the reason why we don't tell people
because they they run to the store and
they'll buy that one nutrient out of the
90 their 90 short or 89 chart, depending
on what number system you use, their
chart, everything else, and then they
die from something else. Well, yeah,
they did what you said and they died.
Okay. [laughter]
Well, we look at the body as a whole,
Dr. Wallik.
>> That's right.
>> Because one piece does not function
unless everything else is functioning
properly also.
>> That's correct.
>> So, we have to feed the body.
>> How do you spell how do you spell When
you say the body's a whole, how do you
spell that?
>> It's W
O L E.
>> Okay.
>> Otherwise, it's a hole missing.
And we don't want any holes in our body,
especially not in our bones and in our
hearts and all that good stuff. We want
to be solid and able to function as we
were designed to do. Well, Dr. W, we're
so close to the top of the hour. Why
don't we go ahead and take a quick
little break here on Ask Doc Live.
Everybody, don't go away because we will
be right back. And
I want to remind you,
get back with the person that invited
you to this program. We do hope that
this is program is offering information
that is getting you thinking about what
you're putting in your mouth because as
epigenetic states,
what we put in our mouths and what we
have in our environment actually is what
influences how our genes are expressed.
Now, if your grandparents had diabetes
and o and arthritis and all those things
and their grandparents did, it's not
because it's genetic. What has been
handed down is a way of eating
and with a continued depletion of soil
and where our food is being grown and
the food that is being fed to our meat
supplies. it's continually
breaking down. And we want to make sure
and be intentional
in knowing that what we're putting into
our bodies is beneficial for our bodies,
supporting ourselves and our body on a
whole. We will be right back onto dock
live. Get up and stretch. Hydrate. Take
deep breaths so that you're getting your
oxygen, so that you're getting your
water because you need both. And we'll
see you in just a minute. All right, and
I am back. Let's see if Dr. Wallik is
back yet.
So everybody, thank you for joining us
here on Ask Doc Live. My name is Becca
Dukes Kak and I am the host of this
program. have been since we started back
in July of 2020 and it is my honor to be
able to host this program. Now, I have
been
really I've been blessed in my own
health journey where I had tried
everything and
I heard Dr. Wallik on a radio program as
many of our listeners have and many of
our subscribers in our newsletter have
heard Dr. wall like on coast to coast
and I'm like that just sounds too easy
but you know what I have tried
everything
so
why not why not
I so I gave Dr. for like 90 days as he
suggested and it has changed my life.
So, not only will have I been able to
get rid of all of my pharmaceuticals and
all of my conditions that I had been
dealing with even since I was eight
years old.
I I feel great and I love the fact that
I am able to age and and I feel like I'm
aging backwards. And Dr. Well, if you
are there, go ahead and unmute yourself
and you can click the okay to start your
video.
There we go. We got the earpieces in. I
think we're ready to get back started.
>> Okay. Hey, can you hear me now?
>> Yes, we can hear you fine. I can even
see you, Doc. [laughter]
>> So,
>> I see you, too.
>> Good. So, let's go back to the salt
because Jenny has a question.
>> Okay.
>> She says, "Does that mean that sea salt
is good for people with thyroid issues?"
So, I don't know if it's just thyroid
issues or I mean all of us that have
thyroids and haven't had it removed.
>> Well, thyroid gland requires all 90
essential nutrients, but there's one.
So, you have to appreciate that all our
tissues require 90 essential nutrients,
but every organ has what we call secret
sauces that it needs. And one of the
secret sauces that the thyroid needs a
lot of is iodine.
Okay? Every little school kid knows that
iodine.
But that's if you just take iodine but
none of the other 89, you're dead.
>> Well, Dr. Wallik, school kids these
days, they're not taught that. And
that's one reason why I love this as
part of my curriculum.
>> No, it's the set, the book, the CD, the
DVD. Yep. Yep.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, there's a book, DVD, and a CD. And
so iodine is found in sea salt. Yes. But
we also have a couple different versions
through longevity that offers the
iodine. We have the ultimate iodine in
liquid drops. So if you feel that you
need additional iodine in your diet, we
have that. Get back with the person that
invited you to this program and ask them
about the iodine products. If you were
not invited to this program by anybody
specific on our website, Asdoc Live, we
do have a store that you can click on
the store and get information. And Dr.
Wallik, you just moved your camera.
>> I'm sorry.
>> You're fine. [laughter]
>> Are we okay now?
>> Um, yeah.
>> Oh, I see what's happening.
>> There we go.
>> Yeah. Okay. I was dragging a book and
the foot of the of the camera sticks out
about 4 inches and I didn't see it. I'm
hitting the that foot.
>> Sorry.
>> I You know what? I'm so proud of you for
just grabbing on to the technology and
being open to do it because not many
people are when they get in this habit
of doing things and especially when
they've been on the road for years
giving inpresent in-person presentations
for it's not just years
>> 30 years
>> decades. Yeah,
>> that's right. And here you are in your
office in front of a computer and still
going strong. So I commend you for even
being a young 83 for grasping onto
technology and
>> thank you so much.
You're a good coach.
>> Well, I'm trying. And I'm trying
[laughter]
as we have many good coaches here
available um to help people find the
right products, the right approach to
their health journey also. So I have
another question here and Angelica wants
to know hydration and elderly.
What would you recommend for the best
hydration?
um but also for helping to build white
blood cells because she has a client
that has low white cell content.
White cells
>> white blood cells are made in the bone
marrow.
So right away that steers you to the
bones.
>> Yes.
>> So you need to get rid of all the bad
stuff so you can absorb the good stuff.
No fried foods, no processed meats, no
oils, no glutens, no wheat, no barats,
no buckwheat. Um,
and then uh want you to take the healthy
brain and heart pack. Healthy brain and
heart pack. Um, uh, let's see here. Do
we know how much this person weighs?
>> We don't. So, let's go with 100 pounds
>> per 100 pounds of body weight. One
healthy brain and heart pack per 100
pounds of body weight. If they only
weigh 105, 110 pounds, be a half of dose
of everything twice a day. If they weigh
150 or more, they need two healthy brain
and heart packs per month. If they weigh
300 lbs or more, they need three healthy
bra hearts amounts and so on. And then
uh for the bone marrow, okay, and the
bone cortex itself, you need per 100
pounds of body weight, one bottle of the
MSM. So you take say three twice a day
per 100 pounds of body weight. That's
going to support and promote main repair
of cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc between the
vertebrae, bone makes a bone itself, and
the bone marrow where the white blood
cells and the red blood cells and the
antibodies and the platelets are made.
Your bone marrow, one of the most
important tissues in your body.
The odds are you will never see your
bone marrow.
The odds are you will never see your own
bone marrow, but it's one of the most
important tissues in your body because
it makes red blood cells, it makes white
blood cells, it makes platelets. I mean,
if you just get a little nick from a
flower thorn, okay? You'll bleed to
death if you don't have platelets. So,
your bone marrow is very, very important
there. Okay? And so, that's what that
that's where you make your white blood
cells is in your bone marrow. So, you
got to go there. And then don't forget
the collagen peptides. Uh, scoop of
that. So, per per 100 pounds of body
weight, I'd go with a scoop for
breakfast drink, scoop for dinner drink.
That'll be two canisters a month and
need the um Beyond Ocio FX, a scoop of
that, a breakfast, scoop of that dinner
drink, and then don't forget the vitamin
D3. Even if you live in a sunny place,
people say, "Well, I live in Hawaii."
Well, how much time do you spend out at
the beach? Well, you know, okay. And so,
when you go to the beach, you take a
umbrella. Oh, yeah. Sit in the shade. We
don't sit out in the sun, you know. Only
visitors sit out in the sun. Okay. Okay,
well there you go. You need the vitamin
D3 if you're not sitting out in the sun.
And so these are basic things that kids
get taught in sixth grade science, but
by the time they're 18 years old, they
kind of forget it. Um they want to go
with the good tasting stuff that makes
them feel better for at least a few
minutes anyway.
>> Well, I know as I'm driving around here
in Southern California and I see people
walking and jogging with umbrellas.
Yep.
>> It's like I would love to be out in the
sun just soaking up that ray. And the
nice thing about it that I've noticed,
Dr. Wallik, since taking the 90
essential nutrients with the essential
fatty acids and the collagen, I can be
out in the sun much longer without going
crispy.
So,
>> correct. I think that is that's just
another bonus um that comes from giving
your body what it needs. And Don so Don
put in the comments here. He said, "One
of my hotel general managers was a U was
in the US Navy and told me that when he
was in the service, the ship's cooks
were only allowed to use white pepper."
So, bravo on that one because that's
that's the only pepper I use. Um, and it
still gives good flavor.
>> Now, Dr. Wellik, um, somebody is talking
about the books and wanting to know, you
know, the your books.
>> They can be found on our website,
askdoccklive.com.
We have many of your popular books
there. Just click on Dr. Wallik's books.
And if you don't find it there, you can
always go to drjwallik.com,
which is Dr. Wallak's website, and find
all of his publications there. All of
the CDs, all the books, all the DVDs,
um, that are offered through wellness
publications.
So, we want to make sure that everybody
has information and access to the
information
about
this valuable information that Dr.
Wallik has put together through his
decades of research.
>> Well, thank you, Beck. And I want to add
a little alert here. Um, we do have four
new books in a 10 CD set coming out. And
[clears throat] the cost of printing
today is like 25% more than it was three
years ago and 50% more than it was 10
years ago. And so, [clears throat] uh,
we're going to have to raise the prices
on all the books. So, if you've been
thinking about buying a book or two,
don't forget you get a big discount if
you buy 10 of any one title. And then
you're going to pay the current prices
if you buy them now. If you wait until
the new price list comes out, uh oh, you
say, "Oh god, I should have bought them
two weeks ago." And so, be thinking
about that. You know, talk to whoever
you need to in your family and so forth.
Get together and um at the very least,
at the very least, you want to get um
rare earth cures. Let's play doctor.
It's all in your head. Dead Doctors
Don't Lie, The Truth About Nutrition,
um, Epigenetics,
Immortality. Get a hold of those books
and you can add 25 to 50 health years
your life just by adding that
information from those books and CDs
that come along with them to
to your lifestyle. I mean, I've been
doing this for 75 years now. Most people
think I'm in my 50s and 60s because of
my energy levels and all that kind of
stuff. And [clears throat] um I started
taking all this stuff when I was nine. I
started taking this stuff when I was
nine, 75 years ago.
Okay. And so so pretty soon I'll be 84.
And I've only been on prescription drugs
three days out of my life. That was um
long time ago. Um when I uh had
infections, okay, for falling at up in
Canada, I fell in a construction ditch.
We had been going down that path forever
um in Canada. It was at night after a
meeting in Canada and we're walking down
this path to go to the parking lot and
the people had used a backhoe to dig a
trench through there and they didn't put
a fence around or any warning or
anything. There was no lights and guess
who stepped in the hole? Me. And of
course I was punctured by all this rebar
and everything, gut infection. So I had
IV antibiotics for three days and that
was it. Other than that
>> and it wasn't Yeah, it wasn't just a
little hole, Dr. Well, like you I saw
pictures. You were kind of shish
kebabed.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> It I
can't imagine. I can't imagine. But you
made it through. You have all of your
toes, all of your feet, all of your
legs. Um, which they wanted to take
those off.
>> Yeah, they did want to take they wanted
to amputate my legs.
>> And they said, "Okay, well, we're going
to have to give you IV antibiotics and
we can't guarantee that you'll live." I
said, "Well, I'd rather die with my legs
on than have you kill me taking my legs
off. So, you're not taking my legs off.
Forget that. Just give me the IV
antibiotics." In three days time, the
infection was down, all the swelling was
down, and I was out of there. and and
you have little to no scarring. You
still have muscle tone. It's it's
incredible, Dr. Wall. Like, after seeing
all the pictures and spending a little
bit of time with you, and it's it's
unbelievable.
And I I know you contributed to having
the nutrition on board already and not
just as a response to getting
>> Oh, yeah. No, I've been taking again.
You know, I was I was in my
uh gosh, I had to be in my 60s.
>> Now, when that happened, Dr. Wallick,
that was less than five years ago.
>> Oh, was it was it less than five years
ago?
>> That was less than five years ago.
>> In my late Yeah, that was my late 70s.
>> You were.
>> Yeah. Most people most people that age
would have died from that trauma.
>> As you say, I was shishab by all that
that by all that rebar and the infection
was horrible.
And uh you know the doctors walk in,
they go, "Whoa, we got to cut those legs
off." No, we're not going there.
>> Yeah. Well, I I'm glad that you didn't
go there. That's for sure. And you made
it through. We're able to continue this
message and just use that as proof that
it works.
So, Dr. Wallik,
>> yes, ma'am.
>> Nancy has a question because we were
just now talking about bone marorrow.
>> Okay. Okay. And what are your thoughts
on bone marrow transplant?
>> Well, there are times when that's
necessary. Um, when people have uh kind
of radiation poisoning or they've been
starving and your bone marrow is dead,
there's nothing to revive because
there's, you know, if you just sort of
give give your bone marrow what it needs
to revive and there's no live bone
marrow cells in there because they took
a a biopsy and there's nothing alive in
there, uh, that's when you need a bone
marrow transplant. So there are times
when you have to do those extreme
things, but they're going to go by blood
type and all this kind of stuff. And so
they're going to match your blood type
so your bone marrow is happy. And but
then they don't all do the same thing.
Here's where in addition to the bone
marrow transplant, they need to jump on
the healthy brain and heart pack, the
MSM, the collagen peptides, beyond osteo
vitamin D3. You need to throw all that
stuff at it at the same time to really
enhance and support that bone marrow
transplant because you want to take care
of that baby.
>> Well, you most definitely do. I mean,
your your blood is manufactured in your
bone marrow. If your bone marrow is not
healthy, you're not going to have
healthy blood, just as you mentioned.
So, we definitely want to make sure that
we're giving our body what it needs to
be healthy on a whole because that blood
is what circulates all the nutrition
throughout the body. And if it's not
circulating and if it's not healthy,
then there's there's no possible way to
have good health.
>> What about oxygen?
>> Well, that has to be circulated through
That's right. that has to be circulated
through the blood, too. And if that
circulation is not helping or not going
through the body, then you're not
getting the oxygen either.
So
it's amazing how everything
it's not a part. Everything is a whole.
It all works together. And you start
taking parts out
then the whole starts to decline as
well.
>> Try driving your car without a fuel
pump.
I've had my fuel pump go out before and
it does not does not go. So, and I've
had the power steering pump go out and
that made it very hard to steer. So,
think about it. You get arthritis in
your bones and joints that makes it hard
to move.
You can still do it,
but not with any type of ease or
comfort.
So let's just be proactive and we can
even be reactive
and get results. I was reactive although
I thought I was being proactive
what I was doing because what was taught
by
people that we trusted was incorrect
information.
And here we're used giving information
that isn't taught on any type of federal
or government level yet.
So Dr. Wallik, let's go to a hand that
is up. Okay.
>> And Deborah, let me go ahead and ask you
to unmute
and welcome to Ask Doc Live.
>> Hello. Hello Doc Wallik.
>> Hello. How can we help you? Um, I have a
client who has had a heart transplant a
few years ago and uh, they won't let her
go on the full 90 because they don't
they're very protective of thinking that
she's going to have some kind of
reaction. It's going to cause some kind
of problems because they're trying, you
know, they got her on meds to keep her
immune system kind of low so she doesn't
reject the heart. So, I'd like some
input about that. And now she has low
iron and they're talking about giving
her iron infusions.
[clears throat and cough]
>> Okay. Well, there's several things going
on here. Number one, she needs to stay
away from all the bad foods. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils, no
glutens, no wheat baron oats, no sugar,
no buckwheat. All that's got to go to
make sure she can absorb nutrients,
right? And [clears throat]
that's not taking anything special.
Let's just get rid of the bad stuff
then. Um, everybody needs 90 essential
nutrients. That's that's a given. And so
they can't say you can't have 90
essential nutrients because that's what
the the good Lord made us with all our
equipment requiring those nutrients,
right? So she needs the 90th essenti.
And then of course the bone marrow
requires um about a dozen different
secret sauces.
And so here's where again
the um what should I say here's where
the the
healthy brain and heart pack come in.
Need all these nutrients to make the
bone marrow happy. And again don't
forget the MSM, don't forget the um
collagen peptides. Don't forget the
Beyond Osteo. Don't forget the vitamin
D3.
And
um this is kind of like grandma's old
bone broth. I don't know if you're old
enough to remember grandma making bone
broth. She'd, you know, take the chicken
bones and beef bones and ribs and stuff
like that and put them in some vinegar
and let them simmer on the wood stove
overnight and then we would all fight to
see who was going to get that bone broth
because it would rebuild your bones.
Okay. Well, that was too difficult to
contemplate doing as a a sales product
for for an international company. So, we
came out with the collagen peptides,
which is bone broth from fish, poultry,
sheep, and beef all in one product. And
so, we've sort of um ramped up on
grandma's recipe,
and that's that's what it's for. It's
replacing bone broth. And so it doesn't
hurt for this person to ask another
doctor say, "Hey, is there any reason
why I can't have, you know, I had a
heart transplant. Is there any reason
why I can't have vitamins and minerals
as a supplement?" Okay. Um,
you know, I'm a little anemic and all
this kind of stuff. I I need something
to help me here. But also they need to
participate by getting rid of the bad
stuff including gluten and the and the
um buckwheat um stuff okay which is the
fago pyrons okay all all that's got to
go and because they cause and contribute
to big big problems
so I hope that helps you I don't know
yeah because I can't say yes or no
because she's not my patient okay But,
uh, she does need these things. And so,
if she's not getting them from her food,
she's getting clinical problems, then
she needs to ask, you know, another
doctor, um,
in her area, um, is it okay if I take
some vitamins and minerals? You know,
I've got this problem, this problem,
this problem, and just eating well for
the last six months hasn't helped me.
It's get slowly getting worse. I need to
take some vitamins minerals, and my
doctor says, don't take vitamins and
minerals. So, what do you think? And so,
you know, kind of have her go that way.
Okay.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Let us know what happens and we'll
be happy to if you want to get a
three-way with her on or if you want to
get her doctor on her here, we'll talk
to her doctor. Okay.
>> That'll be fun,
>> right? [laughter]
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Doc.
>> All right. Thank you, Deborah. Great
question. which then addressed a
question that somebody else had in the
comments about buckwheat. So, I hope he
was able to listen and hear that answer
as well. Now, Dr. Wallik
Nancy brings up the fact that nobody has
brought up ALS in a while. Okay? And it
possible that people don't bring it up
because they've been told that it is
incurable.
So what are your comments on ALS?
>> Okay, amalotropic lateral scerosis of
course um has to do with um
[clears throat]
what should I say it it goes along with
um let's see here Parkinson's disease.
It goes along with Alzheimer's disease.
It goes along with Tourett syndrome. It
goes along with MS. It goes along with
all those things. And these are all
nutritional deficiencies including ALS.
And so people with ALS need to get rid
of all the bad foods. No, no gluten, no
wheat ran oats, no buckwheat, okay? No
fagopyrons. And then need to take three
eggs twice a day if they're adults.
Three eggs twice a day with soft yolks.
And then of course they need the healthy
brain and heart pack. They need the
collagen peptides.
uh they need to take the um let's see
here
I also have them take the synaptive
three of those twice a day I have them
take the memory effects three of those
twice a day and uh that's kind of where
I would start
>> what about so the ALS really affects the
the sheath my mil myelin sheath on the
nerves
>> and I know our ultimate nascin has
ingredients in it that help to promote
the health of that sheath.
>> Okay. Well, go for ultimate nasin also
can hurt. I take that. I take one of
those at breakfast, one dinner time. If
I take two, I get all that that um hot
>> and see I'm I'm opposite. I have to take
two at a time or I get a hot flush and
flush and and go ahead share with us a
little bit what that is if you would.
>> Well, it's a it's a sudden dilation of
your blood vessels caused by the nascin.
the blood vessels suddenly dilate and
you just get this hot flash. Okay. And
so
>> because the blood is flowing, right?
>> That's correct.
>> Isn't that what we want it to do?
>> That's correct. And so I don't I don't
mind a mild one, but I don't I don't
want a hot flash that puts me out of
business. I mean, you know, just so so
disruptive it just can't I'm sorry. I'll
be back in 15 minutes kind of thing.
[clears throat]
>> Well, and the nice thing about it
though, Dr. olic is it doesn't last very
long and it is about 15 20 minutes for
most people and something that you can
do is drink extra water. Make sure that
you're staying hydrated.
>> And you think about it, when you're
taking the Healthy Read and Heart Pack,
you're taking 215
separate nutrients.
And then I throw in you, you know,
you've visited us, you've seen the table
with all my supplements on it. I have 55
bottles on the table. So, I take the 215
nutrients plus my 55 additional
supplements on top of that. I'm taking
about 270 different nutrients, okay?
Twice a day. That's twice a day. And so,
what can I say? Uh, it's one of those
things where
you you put your priorities where
they're at. Well, my priorities are to
live to be at least a minimum of 200,
but I think 400, 600 is even better, but
a minimum of 200 is about right. And so
we have so many people to help, so many
people that need information and they're
suffering terribly from simple things
that we can pass on information to them
and help them get through this uh
without, you know, a catastrophe. And so
you have to be personally responsible
and take care of yourself. So yeah, if
you're 200 years old, people got to
listen to you when it comes to aging. If
you, you know, if you're, you know, in
the emergency room dying and you're 40,
nobody's going to listen to you about
health.
That's true. I know. The first time I
saw that table, Dr. Wallik, it's like
it's a it's a 2x5 table, folks.
And he's got a little bit of space where
he lines up his bottles.
And three feet of that 1x3 minimum is
packed full of the supplements. He is a
product of the product.
>> And now that's not the 90 essential
nutrients. That's those are my add-ons.
>> Those are special sauces. That's right.
>> Secret sauces. Special sauces. Yep.
>> Yep. And then on the counter right there
in front of the refrigerator, you got
your tangy tangerine, your osteo
effects, and your collagen peptides. So,
and then the the canister of the
rebound. I like the canister of the
rebound because it does have less sugar.
And many people ask, well, if doc's not
for carbonation, why do they make a
carbonated drink? And folks,
we have to meet people where they're at.
When people are out there buying
handover fist canned drinks
that provide artificial energy
and it's it it's it's from sugar and
caffeine which creates a spike in their
blood sugar and then a drop.
You've got to meet people where they're
at. We got to put something in a can
like what they've been wanting to buy so
that they'll want to buy it also. And
unfortunately, carbonation helps to
satisfy another one of those reasons
people buy that drink.
>> Let me add a piece to your answer there.
Everybody's heard of Red Bull.
>> That is the most bestselling
what they say power drink. Power drink.
>> Red Bull. And one of the co-founders of
the Red Bull company who manufactured it
died about two weeks ago. They haven't
released his cause of death yet. I'm
very very interested in his co. It was
sudden. He he was just he just died in
his sleep one night and no previous
illnesses or anything. And he had
bragged for many years and I had gone to
several other meetings and he bragged
for many years that he was drinking 10
cans of Red Bull every day for 25 years.
It's all carbonated, right? And um so I
finally got digging into what is Red
Bull? Well, it's caffeine. It's sugar.
Um it is uh let's see here. It has all
the B vitamins in it. All the B
vitamins. And it does have one mineral,
magnesium.
It doesn't have 60 minerals in it. Okay.
Our rebound has 75 minerals in it,
including the 60 essential minerals,
including magnesium.
Okay.
>> Yeah. And so um Red Bull is not a
complete supplement where our rebound is
a complete supplement except for
essential fatty acids.
Okay, it has all 90 essential nutrients
except for the essential fatty acids.
And so that's that's a big difference
between a high sugar, high caffeine one
mineral
drink car which is carbonated the Red
Bull and one of the co-founders died. I
think he is 75
or 78 somewhere in there. Um suddenly
just went to sleep that night, didn't
wake up in the morning. And so um you
know and I'm sure he was a very nice
man. And so it's one of those things
where uh you have to kind of look and
say, "Okay, do I want to go that
direction or do I want to take the the
rebound?" And if I like canned drinks, I
would just pop the top like Wall does
and leave it off gas the carbonation at
night and drink it flat. All the bubbies
gone in the morning.
>> I like to drink it with a banana.
Mix it all up
>> and it's just so good.
>> I love it. that,
>> but not the can. I use the powder in the
canister um so that I'm not getting all
of that sugar because sugar creates fat.
It's not fat that creates fat, folks.
Sugar creates fat. So, we stay away from
sugar. We don't have that high blood
sugar spike and drop. What?
>> And mineral deficiencies cause fat. And
mineral defici well yes because mineral
deficiencies your body thinks it's
starving so it's going to hold on to
everything that it does get
>> and you're gonna eat more and more and
more which is
>> yeah you'll eat 10 meals a day instead
of three
>> well you know what study that you
mentioned that Dr. Well, I there was a
time in my largest moments
where they were saying to eat six small
meals a day.
So, I was eating those six small meals a
day. I calculated it. One day my small
meals were like 2400 calories
>> each
>> and very little nutrition. No, not each.
Not each, but twice the amount that what
I should have been eating if going by a
1,200 calorie diet to lose weight, which
I I'm kind of losing some trust. No, I
did I did lose a lot of trust in their
studies because none of them were
working for me. And I got on your
program. My first three months, I lost
20 pounds. I wasn't even trying. And
it's because I was giving the body those
minerals. The body no longer felt like
it was in starvation mode and it started
releasing and now I'm down 105 pounds.
So I think it works. I do.
Thank you.
>> Well, you're very
>> Thank you for being on the radio for all
these years, Dr. Wallik, and talking to
the air because I my ears heard that air
and I greatly appreciate it. Let's go to
Ivonne who has her hand up patiently.
Ivonne, go ahead and unmute yourself.
You're on live with Dr. Wallik.
>> Hi, you caught me. Um, I needed about a
twominut warning. Give me a second.
>> Unfortunately, I can't say Ivonne,
you're up next in two minutes.
>> Oh, darn it.
>> But there you are, beautiful.
>> Hey. Hi, Doc. Good morning.
>> Good to see you again.
Um, so I have a 67y old. She's 130 uh
pounds. Uh, she's developed over the
last I think six plus years. Basically,
she describes it as hardening from the
inside out. She has a calcium, very,
very large calcium
um, cutaneous, you know, like um, in her
wrist. Uh she's got some calcifications
in the lungs, in the kidneys. Um her
skin is extremely tight and shiny. Uh
they have decided that she has
scaraderma.
How can we help her? And what's going
on? Is it a calcium issue? Is it a
deficiency?
>> Okay. Well, scaraderma uh is a
nutritional deficiency. It It's actually
like osteoporosis
of the skin.
>> Wow.
>> Okay. Derma is skin.
>> Yeah.
>> Sclera is scarring. Okay. Scaraderma.
So, she needs to get rid of all the bad
stuff. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat by
ryanos, no sugar, no carbonated drinks
of any kind. Um, no buckwheat. And then
I want her to um have let's see here.
She weighed
>> 30. She Oh yeah, I see 130 pounds. So
she she needs to I since she has
scaroderm and it can be lead to fatal
things. So she needs to get two healthy
brain and heart packs per month. Two
healthy brain and heart packs a month. A
full everything twice a day. I want to
get two bottles a month of our MSM. So
you could take three at breakfast, three
at lunch at dinner time. She needs um
let's see here two canisters of the
collagen peptides. So she could take a
scoop of that with her breakfast drink,
a scoop of that with her evening drink.
I want her also to uh take our vitamin
D3 three of those twice a day. I also
want her to have uh let's see here,
skin, and nails. I want her to get two
bottles a month of hair, skin, and
nails. So, she could take um
three of those. I'd have her take three
three times a day. She has scared. I'd
have her take three three times a day of
the hair, skin, and nails. And let's see
here. Um,
I think that's going to cover the
waterfront. That's going to cover the
waterfront. Um,
and again, she's got to stay away from
all the bad stuff so she can maximize
absorption of all these things. And
let's see here. Becca, did I miss
anything?
>> You're muted, Becca.
>> I think you got it. I think you got it,
Doc.
>> Okay. We we just want to make sure we're
supporting the connective tissue and
have all those those co-actors so that
the calcium could actually be utilized
where it's needed.
>> So no extra well you're going to have
EFAs since you said healthy brain and
extra EFAs.
>> Yeah. Two healthy brain and heart packs.
So she'll be able to take three EFAs and
three EFA pluses
>> twice a day.
>> And why the um D3? That sounds like the
capsules. Can I give her the the um the
spritz?
the citra. The citro citra. Oh, yeah.
Either way, anything works as long as D3
because this is where um this is how you
help your body absorb particularly
calcium, okay? And put it in all the
right places including the bones and the
skin and cartilage and ligaments and all
this connective tissue. Um, you need
that vitamin D3. And again, people knew
in the old days that if you didn't have
sunlight, you'd get trouble. You get
ricketetts. Kids would get ricketetts if
they didn't have the sunlight. Uh and of
course ricketetts, it was a big big big
deal. uh when suddenly um they were
burning coal uh in big cities and when
they were burning coal you know to make
electricity and stuff like that uh it it
clouded out the sun and and ricketetts
went crazy uh in the big cities uh
because of that.
And doc, real quick, she uh questioned
um when I gave her some stuff, she said,
"Well, I have to have, you know, K2 with
my D3, but there were no minerals in her
D3 and K2. Um can you can you talk on
that?
>> Well, if she wants to get K2, just add
it to uh ours. Don't replace anything
because her K2 only has K2.
>> Yeah.
She's gonna give up five nutrients to
take one. No, it doesn't make sense.
>> Good approach. Yeah. Thank you so much.
>> Yeah. And she K2 to it.
>> Sorry, Doc.
>> No, no, go ahead.
>> Ivon, don't go anywhere. Dr. Wallik, I
love the fact that we have practitioners
that are so instrumental in making sure
that your programs and supplements are
being utilized within their practices.
Mhm.
>> And Ivon's one of them. I just love her
to death.
>> And she brought up a very good point in
regards to B vitamins because I had seen
some articles recently about B vitamins
and one of them talking about synthetic
B vitamins being toxic to our bodies.
And so I went looking up that form of B
in our supplements and we didn't have
it. I was so so excited. We had the the
natural non-synthetic form of B
vitamins, which when you look at Red
Bull, it's got synthetic B vitamins.
>> Oh, there you go.
>> Not natural.
>> So, thank you so much for reminding me
of that, Ivonne.
>> Absolutely. And I think that's one thing
that we all here need to remember when
you are questioned with um something
like that. Well, my doctor says remember
and and doc, help us out here. something
like 99.9% of all of these research
articles are on synthetic nutrients made
in a laboratory, not plant food. So, you
have to, you know, educate yourself,
educate your um your customers and your
family, and you will make a an even
bigger difference.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. And of course, doctors don't get
much training for nutrition except the
salesman come by and they give them a
sample or something like that. Um
[clears throat]
um a sixth grader can know more about
nutrition than a doctor does. A doctor,
all they say is just eat well, you get
everything you need. That's an
absolutely false statement. Every time a
doctor should say that, they should
spend 10 years in jail or just eat while
you get everything you need. That's not
possibly true. It's not possible to be
true.
>> Not at all. And one more thing, Avon,
thank you so much for your service as I
know that you did serve in our armed
forces as well.
>> Thank you.
>> Absolutely. What branch of the service
did you
>> I was in the Navy. Uh also served with
the Marines and um worked in the dental
and the medical field.
>> Well, thank you so much. God bless you
for your service.
>> Hey, thank you for your book, Doc.
That's how I got introduced to you. Um
when I was reading the um
>> Was it Dead Doctors Don't Lie?
>> Oh, no, no, no. The big one. The one
that cost me uh the price of a small
car.
>> Okay. Yeah, it was a $25,000 one.
>> Yes. Yes.
or I should still reading it. I'm about
>> can I have a good I have good news about
that. That book, the diseases of exotic
animals was my 20,000 autopsies. Okay,
20,000 auto autops are represented in
that book. And it was a 10-year study,
$25 million study and proved there were
no genally transmitted diseases, there's
no autoimmune diseases. And of course,
we sold out like in 90 days, sold out.
And of course the replacement for it
because the average person is not going
to spend $25,000 is epigenetics. Okay,
it's kind of a summary of that book.
Okay, epig. Thank you. Okay, is is a is
a summary of it. Now the good news is
um we have the book The Disease of
Exotic Animals, a $25,000 book at the
printers right now and they're printing
each chapter is going to be a book. Oh,
fantastic.
>> So, you can buy the uh books chap the
book the chapter at a time. Okay. And
so, I'm very excited about that and it's
going to go very quickly because of all
the equipment we have now with all the
computers and this that and the other.
And so, we're going to buzz through this
and so it's going to be made available
here pretty soon and it's going to floor
people. It's going to freak people out.
>> Will that be marketed to veterinarians
or to
>> Oh, no. No. to humans,
>> how it relates to disease, nutrition,
and how it
>> relates how how it relates to human
disease.
>> Fantastic.
Fantastic. I know sometimes people ask
me, why are you reading that? You know,
they don't they don't understand what
you did.
>> Well, not only that, um, most of the
research in nutrition for humans is done
in rabbits and mice and guinea pigs.
It's all done in animals and pigs and
calves and horses.
>> Yes.
>> And so forth. It's not done in people
because you have to kill them at the end
of the study. You do all all the the
microscopic stuff and chemistry and so
forth. And so that wouldn't work, you
know, unless you're a Nazi. Okay.
>> Well, I hope you'll be promoting that
strongly.
>> Oh, yeah. As soon as as soon as the
first um um supply comes off the
printers, uh we will be punching that
hard because everybody will be everybody
will be able to afford it.
>> Becca, can I get a um um can you help me
get a signed copy?
>> I can help you get a signed copy.
Absolutely.
[laughter]
>> And thank you again so much for your
service. We love you. Thank you so much
for your service. God bless you.
>> Thank you.
Thank you, Avon.
>> Thank you, Becca. And you and your team
do
>> Navy and the Marines. Holy moly.
>> She's She's a powerhouse, Doc.
>> Wow.
>> She's a powerhouse. We have a lot of
powerhouses in our longevity family.
>> What state does she What state does she
live in now?
>> She's in our state. She's in California.
>> Oh,
>> just farther north. And
yeah, so
Dr. We have h there's so many things I
want to talk about and we're almost out
of time.
>> Okay.
>> So, we only have 10 more minutes.
>> Well, we have two hours of radio coming
up this afternoon.
>> Yes. So, we have dead Doctors. that is
aired on ko1080
a.m. And if you go to their website
ko.com
and then click on komy or do a search
better yet do a search for dead doctors
don't lie. It will give you the
information that you need in order to
jump on and have a whole another hour of
being able to ask Dr. wallet questions
in regards to your health there on the
air. And folks, don't be shy. Somebody
else out there is experiencing the same
thing that you are experiencing and they
may be listening to that syndicated
program and because of your question,
you could be also helping them change
their life and create a better health
journey for them as well. So, we
encourage you to jump on to Dr. Wallik's
radio programs also Monday through
Friday from 12 to 1 p.m. Pacific time.
And then I apologize, I don't know all
of the information for the Let's Play
Doctor. Um, is that is that's another
affiliation that I'm not part of, but I
love KC. That's from uh
>> 1 to two, but both those stations are uh
AM radio and um been doing that for over
32 years.
>> 32 years. That's called longevity. Dr.
Wall, that's like stickness.
>> Stick.
>> So stick tuitiveness. And for those of
you who are on the Zoom with us, Ruth
Ellen just put the information in the
chat on how you can plug in and make a
phone call and ask Dr. Wallik on his
program. Um, I'm honored to be on with
you on Wednesdays on that program.
>> Yes,
>> you're a co-host. That's awesome.
Wednesdays. Yes.
>> I think it's absolutely fabulous. And I
want to know where people are joining us
in from. And I asked that question in
the chat, Dr. Wallik. And I know for a
fact we have people in V West Virginia
and Virginia and South Carolina, North
Carolina, Utah, Washington, California,
Pennsylvania,
um, of course California. I think I said
that already. We also have
[clears throat] South Africa, Dr.
Wallik, um, outside of Johannesburg.
>> Yes. Thank you very much.
>> That's opportunity list. Yeah,
>> I'm gonna learn it. I really am. I I
promise, Albert. I'm gonna learn it. Um
and I love the fact that we are reaching
around the world. We've got the UK.
Um yes, Blue Ridge, Virginia. I I think
it's fabulous, Dr. Wallik, that and more
people are plugging in here. Sacramento,
California.
Uh Los Angeles. I know Angelica's in the
Los Angeles area. It's just absolutely
fantastic. And if you are watching this
program because somebody referred you to
it, we hope that you did get information
that is beneficial for you in helping
you reach your health journeys. And
welcome Phoenix, Arizona and Oregon.
Awesome. They keep keep them coming.
Keep them coming. Yeah, I'm still
licensed as a physician in Oregon.
Naturopathic physician.
>> So, you're licensed as a naturopathic
physician in Oregon and in California.
>> California. That's correct.
>> Yep. Absolutely. And of course, you've
been a veterinarian around the world.
>> Yes.
>> And people people forget, Dr. Wallik,
>> two years in South Africa.
>> Two years in South Africa. But
vertebrates, we are a vertebrate. We're
a mammal with a backbone.
And vertebrates have like all of the
different functions that we do. Yes.
Rhino Express.
>> Stay right. There's only 350 left back
then. Now there's 21,000. So I'm very
proud of that.
>> Absolutely.
Absolutely. And that's that's like a
little adventure book for kids. So, if
you have a um not too young of a reader,
but if you have a young reader or
somebody that's into adventure books,
that would be a great stocking stuffer
for your loved ones, whether nieces,
nephews, children, grandchildren, the
neighbor kid. Go to drjwall.com.
You'll be able to find Rhino Express
there. And
goodness, what else? So, we did have a
question in regards to sugar, Dr.
Wallik.
>> Well, sugar, sugar in small amounts is a
good fuel. That's all it is. It's a fuel
that you burn it and you keep you keep
your calories going. So, your various
functions and organs can do their job as
well as move your muscles and move from
here to there. Um, and so sugar in
modest amounts is not a bad thing. But
like all things even oxygen and too much
uh you know you rust inside when you
have too much oxygen. [clears throat]
Okay things oxidize and they turn into
bad things they turn into cancer. And so
you have to make sure uh even water you
drown if you have too much water. Water
is important for hydration but if you
take too much water you can dilute your
nutrients over a long period of time and
and get nutritional deficiencies if you
drink too much water. but also um you
can drown uh if you drink too much
water. Okay. And so um it's one of those
things where uh you know when this um
co-founder of Red Bull died um we're
they haven't released his cause of death
yet. I don't know if they have asked the
coroner not to do that or or why, but
that's been two weeks. They should know
by now what he died from. And um I keep
looking but I don't find it being I keep
asking Siri, you know, what did he die
from? And it says cause of death not yet
posted. Okay, so we shall see
eventually. Um we have to wait till all
those doctors die.
>> Well, oh my goodness,
that's not very nice, Dr. Wall. Well, I
said, "Wait,
>> we don't want to wish we don't want to
wish death on anybody, even though it's
>> I mean, eventually all of us are going
to leave this life as we know it,
>> but to to wish it on anybody, we don't
want to do that. And we want to
promote." I know you're not wishing, but
you're just waiting. But so [laughter]
Nancy Nancy has a cute little story that
she put in um in the chat and she said I
quit sugar intake at 29 years old and I
know she's a few few years beyond that
and she said that at night she dreamed
of eating cheesecake and custard eclairs
for two straight weeks and then she was
free of any interest in sweets ever
again. So, she went through that
detoxification stage, folks. And if you
plug through, push through, and
especially if you're giving your body
the 90 essential nutrients,
you will get through it. And with the 90
essential nutrients doc, it didn't take
very long. I did not have those cravings
for those sweet things anymore.
I didn't I still don't. And
>> yeah, I don't have any cravings.
>> Been through emotional stuff. Yeah. I've
been through emotional stuff. been
through this, you know, women, men too,
they go through hormonal changes. Yeah,
I I think that we all do. And I'm No,
I'm not going to ask you, doc. I'm just
going to tell you, you do. Um,
and when your body is neutrified, you
don't have those swings.
And I'm going to get my co-hosts on here
with me because they have done such a
great job making sure that the chat is
running smooth, making sure that
everybody that has their camera on is
doing what they're supposed to do and
just answering questions in the chat. I
absolutely love and appreciate them. And
Heather, Ruth, Ellen, Janty, Dr. Wallik,
thank you so much for being part of Ask
Doc Live.
>> Thank you. We love you.
>> Another week,
>> another week of being able to provide
information that people aren't going to
get in other places.
So, share it, share it, share it, share
it, share it with everyone you know. Um,
do a search. Our critical health news
YouTube page has all of our replays
also. So you can go through there, look
at the different topics that we offer.
Also on the critical
news.com website, look at the different
topics. You will, I know, think of
somebody. I was like, "Oh, I know that
person that's suffering from that. I
know that person that's dealing with
that." Share that video with them. make
sure that they at least have the
opportunity to get information that
could change their lives and help them
find a new health journey that they will
be happier with. So on behalf of Asdoc
Live, my name is Rebecca Dukes and we
appreciate you spending this time with
us on Asdoc Live. Bye for now.
>> Bye bye. Love you. Bye. Bye. Love you
too, Doc. Love you. Love you.